i do want to talk about certificates at
some point but kind of the way that the
certificates work
is that they have these really important
digital signatures at the bottom
and they kind of underpin the whole
thing
so rob did a video already on public key
cryptography which is a really good
watch and you should definitely you know
check that out
so if you recall in public key you have
a public key and you have a private key
and they're kind of the inverse of one
another so you can encrypt with one and
decrypt the other one
so i can for example if you have a
public key i can encrypt something with
it and send it to you
right but actually we don't tend to do
that very often we could do that
but encryption with something like rsa
is not that quick
and for very long messages becomes a
little bit impractical
there are other reasons as well in terms
of the fact that we use these keys for
very long time
and people prefer to rotate keys more
often so these days
for actual encryption what we would tend
to do is just encrypt things using
something like aes
and symmetric keys so you use this kind
of thing to
verify who you are and then move on and
establish something else yeah that's
exactly right
the way that we use something like rsa
or the other signature schemes
is going to be that we verify the
identity of one of the people in the
conversation and then we revert to
regular symmetric photography
right and we'll have got done a key
exchange or something like this i mean
we talked about this in the
tls video right so part of tls is a
certificate and a digital signature
and it only forms a part of the
handshake after which we just
consider that done and then we move on
right um so what is a digital signature
right that's i suppose it's the first
question
in my head i've got this idea of kind of
like a bitmap 8-bit version of
signing your name right i mean there are
obviously lots of cryptographic things
that we have to tick off right to make
sure it's not forgeable
but the idea is that i have a document
or a message or something that i want to
send you
and i want to prove that it was me that
sent it and so to do that i'm going to
use my private key
to sign a digital signature and
basically what you're going to do on
your end is verify
that signature and verify that it was
actually me but encrypted it
that that's the idea so when we perform
this process what we tend to think of is
the person that's doing the signing and
the person that's doing the verification
right now i you know i might nod to rsa
or something like this but really this
applies to any signature scheme
so we have the signer over here and we
have the verifier
over here right is that hasbro verifier
i think so yeah okay we've got some
document or something like this
or message for now let's not worry about
how long it is or what it is right it
could be a letter
it could be you know a mortgage
application
it could just be part of a tls handshake
message it's not it's not really
important
now this document is not currently
encrypted and
we're going to send it over to the
verifier
like this right as part of our
conversation right now
the problem with that is there could be
someone in the middle changing this
document forging it this could be a fake
document you know
we don't know that it's come from me
this is over the internet and so when
you send something over the internet you
can't guarantee
that someone um hasn't changed something
or done something they shouldn't be
doing
now if we had an encrypted connection
where we knew we had
we each had a key that would help but
we've still got the issue of how do you
do this when you establish the key and
during the initial handshake and things
like this so digital signatures form a
big part of these kind of systems
because at the beginning at least you're
going to have to prove one of the
identities
at least otherwise you're going to be
finding no one knows who anyone else is
and that's going to be a huge problem
okay so what the signer is going to do
is create a digital signature
so they're going to take the document
and we'll just simplify for a minute and
then we'll build up a little bit of of
sort of information in a while right and
they're going to encrypt it
with their private key right and this is
basically exactly like
bob described right so this will form a
signature now they're the only ones that
could have done that
right because they only they're the only
ones that have the private key right
otherwise none of this works
right if they've got to do that way they
then send the signature over
to the verifier right over the internet
and the ver and the verifier can perform
this verification process so they can
basically say well okay
what if we take this signature and we
decrypt it with the public key
all right so this is the signature here
what if we do take this and we
decrypt it with the public key because
remember they reverse one another
and then we can sort of work out whether
the document
and the signature match right because if
it was the original document that was
encrypted using a private key
that original document is going to pop
back out again and then
we can verify that that's actually taken
place if that's a big document
isn't this a bit wasteful because you
know if it's gigabytes like the video
files that i might send
is that not a bit wasteful too that's it
a huge problem right which is what i've
oversimplified it right and everyone
watching the video who knows about this
is going to be like when are you going
to talk about hashing right well now now
we're going to talk about hashing
um this is this is an oversimplification
because the problem is that this
document could be any length
right and it's a problem if it's very
very long but it's also a problem if
it's very very short
right if your document is literally the
number one
the encryption using rsa of that with
any key is also one
right as a sort of contrived example
right
so signature schemes like rsa don't work
well when you have very very short
messages
and we start to run into problems of
computational efficiency
and the fact that you're going to have
to split the message up and sign
multiple bits and then they can be
reordered and there's all kinds of
attacks that you can run on this
so this isn't going to quite work right
we want a scheme that will work however
long the document is or however short
the document is
so we're going to mix this up a bit
right what we're going to do is i'm
going to change my pen color it's all
very exciting we're going to insert
a hash function here so this is going to
be a hash function
h right and you know we might use
something like sha256 for this
now that will take as you know any
message length
and turn it into a length of exactly 256
bits
right which for this purpose is going to
help us a lot we're also probably going
to want to add some padding
because typically 256 bits is quite
short for
this kind of signature scheme so you'd
usually sign a longer message than this
again you don't know what the output of
the hash is going to be if the hash ends
up very very small
right like in blockchain that could be a
security risk we don't take that risk
so we take the document and we summarize
it using a hash function maybe we add
some padding or some other mechanism
like this
and then we encrypt it using the private
key
so this this arrow here goes away and
we're going to take our private key
and encrypt it there instead so now the
verifiers process has to change slightly
to
basically to match so we're going to
take the document
and we're going to hash it and then
we're going to possibly add some padding
and perform the exact same process and
we can work out whether that
unsigned signature which is what we've
got is going to match the one that's
been decrypted using the public key
what we will normally do is ship these
both off together
in a conversation so as an example in
tls
you will send a bunch of messages to
each other and then at some point
you will send a certificate with a um
that has a public key on it
and you will send a certificate verify
message in tls 1.3
for example which has a summary of some
of the previous messages
hashed padded and
encrypted using a private key right to
verify
so you don't actually send a document
because the document is the previous tls
messages right so you know what that
document is
we know what it is that we can we have
to be checking against
basically you're doing a a comparison
right between what you've already
received that you've then hashed an ad
padding to
and then what you receive as the kind of
authorization or confirmation that that
should be the right thing
how do we we know what padding and stuff
is that like a system is it like a set
that's a great question yes so we would
usually use something like the
probabilistic signature scheme for rsa
right and and these introduce
essentially a
formal structure for doing this they
also tend to add something like a salt
or a random number
which means that um messages encrypt
differently each time there's never a
secret
it's just that it it it helps with the
implementation and the security
we're talking about any document here
this isn't the certificate that we sort
of started talking about at the
beginning is it
it could be it could be and often it is
one of the primary
roles for digital signatures is on the
ends of certificates right as part of
public key infrastructure
now we could spend a long time talking
about public key infrastructure perhaps
another time
the idea is we have a certificate for a
server for example backed by a private
key you know kept on the server
um and that sign that so and that
certificate holds their public key
and it has a digital signature on it but
signed by some certification authority
right and tom has covered this in his
video on superfish right
and this is a huge part of the modern
internet it's a huge part of tls
mainly because if you remember when
you're doing this handshake
the server sends a certificate and you
verify that certificate by basically
looking at it and making sure it's been
signed properly by a certification
authority
that you trust right and the process you
use to verify
is this right you take the bytes from
the content of a certificate
you hash them you pad them right or you
use a probabilistic signature scheme or
something like this
and then you decrypt the signature using
their public key and you compare them
right and if they match you've got a
long way to proving that that's a real
signature on the end of that certificate
and that it's a legitimate server you're
talking to
the problem with this is we've got to
share all these public keys we've got to
share these public key certificates
we have to have some mechanism where
certification authorities
sign them and then we can check them and
things like this right and this
whole sort of structure is called public
key infrastructure and we'll talk about
that in the next video
i actually managed to install it on a
windows 98 virtual machine the other day
it took me back a bit
a few people you know the nsa had been
looking at this netscape have been
looking at this other groups have been
looking at this idea of web encryption
themselves to click through but you know
you try
okay the attacker can't intercept the
keys anymore not without sending up